THAT'S HOW CLOSE THEY ARE.
THEY KNEW THEY WOULD TRY TO
START THEIR OWN.
THE MINORITY DEMOCRATS ARE AS WE
SAID BACK IN THE HOUSE.
THE SPEAKER IN A GROWING NUMBER
OF DEMOCRATS PUBLICLY VOICING
OPPOSITION TO NANCY PELOSI FOR
THAT JOB FOR ANOTHER TIME.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
TALKED ABOUT FREQUENTLY ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL WAS THE NEED TO
HAVE NEW VOICES IN CONGRESS AND
THE NEED TO TURN THE NEW PAGE.
>> WE ANSWER THAT CALL FOR NEW
LEADERSHIP BY REESTABLISHING THE
SAME STATUS QUO AND LEADERSHIP
THAT WE'VE HAD SINCE 2006.
>> OTHER PEOPLE THROW THEIR HAT
IN THE RING, TOO.
>> THE MOST OBVIOUS IS BY
SAYING, LOOK.
THAT'S 39 SEATS IN THE HOUSE AND
POSSIBLY WE WILL GET TO 40.
I DID THAT, AND INSTEAD SHE'S
CRYING SEXISM.
>> YOU WOULD HAVE TO ASK THOSE
PEOPLE WHAT THEIR MOTIVATION IS.
AND AND IF THERE IS ANY MISOGYNY
INVOLVED, IT'S THEIR PROBLEM.
STORM ACT RICHARD GOODSTEIN IS A
LIVING EXPERT ON THIS.
HE IS AN ATTORNEY AND FORMER
ADVISOR.
I DIDN'T KNOW RICHARD THAT THERE
WAS NOT MUCH SEXISM IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WHAT ARE YOU GUYS GOING TO DO
ABOUT IT?
>> I WAS SORRY TO SEE
NANCY PELOSI ATTRIBUTE THOSE
REBELS TO MISOGYNY AND SEXISM.
I ACTUALLY THINK SHE KNOWS THAT
THAT'S NOT WHAT IT IS.
WHEN CONNOR LAM WAS RUNNING FOR
ELECTION, AND ALL THESE ADS ARE
BEING RUN SAYING HE'S GOING TO
BE A PUPPET OF NANCY PELOSI.
IT'S NOT BECAUSE HE'S A MOMENT
BUT BECAUSE HE MADE A COMMITMENT
TO HIS CONSTITUENTS BECAUSE HE
BASICALLY THOUGHT THAT'S WHAT HE
NEEDED TO DO TO, A, GET ELECTED,
AND B, DO WHAT HE THOUGHT WAS
RIGHT.
>> Tucker: SO HE JUST WANTS
THE MOST QUALIFIED CANDIDATE,
IRRESPECTIVE OF HER.
I CAN'T LET YOU OFF THE HOOK
THAT FAST, RICHARD.
THESE ARE THE RULES THAT YOU
GUYS WROTE AND THE RULES ARE AS
FOLLOWS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING ABOUT
YOU IS HOW YOU ARE BORN.
YOUR, YOUR RACE, YOUR
PREFERENCE, AND YOUR INEQUALITY
IS, YOUR DNA.
IT'S CALLED IDENTITY, I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU KNEW THAT, IN THE
INTERSECTIONAL WORLD THAT YOU
GUYS MADE, YOU CAN'T JUST SAY,
WE FOUND A BETTER CANDIDATE.
YOU ARE BLOWING OFF A WOMAN AND
14 MEN ARE DOING THAT THE
PROBLEM FOR THE DEMOCRATS, AND
THEY ARE GOING TO PUT THE
YOUNGER, VITAL, EVIL, COMPETENT
PEOPLE IN OUR LEADERSHIP
POSITION, AND PAUL RYAN IS A
YOUNG GUY.
I THINK THAT SOMETHING THAT
FRANKLY, A LOT OF DEMOCRATS
WISH -- DEMOCRATS WISH THEY
COULD FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
APPRAISE.
NOTHING TO DO WITH NANCY PELOSI
NANCY PELOSI'S GENDER OR
CONGRESSMAN CLYBOURN'S RACE.
>> REALLY?
EVERYTHING OUTSIDE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S LEADERSHIP
STRUCTURE ACCORDING TO DEMOCRATS
HAVE TO DO WITH RACE AND GENDER,
EVERYTHING.
EVERY TIME I FLIP ON THE TUBE
THERE IS SOME TUGGING HIS CHIN
AND SAYING, I DON'T SEE ENOUGH
PEOPLE OF WHATEVER IN THIS
PICTURE.
THAT'S THE MOST BASIC DEMOCRATIC
TALKING POINT.
BUT WE AREN'T SUPPOSED TO APPLY
IT TO THE DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP,
BECAUSE WHY?
>> I THINK THE DEMOCRATIC
TALKING POINTS ARE ABOUT
HEALTH CARE, ABOUT TAXES GOING
TO WORKING PEOPLE, ABOUT GUN
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
>> CAN I I TO STOP LECTURING T
>> CAN I I TO STOP LECTURING E
REST OF US?
THAT'S ALL I'M ASKING FOR.
I HOPE THE DEMOCRATS TALK ABOUT
HEALTH CARE, I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT TOPIC.
CAN THEY LAY OFF THE RECENT
GENDER STUFF >> REPUBLICANS PUT
NANCY PELOSI ON THE BALLOT.
DEMOCRATS PICKED UP 39 SEATS,
NOTHING TO DO WITH RACE OR
GENDER BUT SOMETHING TO DO WITH
THE BELIEF THAT THEY NEEDED AN
AGENDA THAT THE DEMOCRATS
SUPPORTED AND FRANKLY TO PUT --
>> NOTHING TO DO WITH RACE OR
GENDER, HOW DO WE KNOW THAT?
HERE'S WHAT I KNOW AND HERE ARE
THE STARK FACTS OF THE CASE.
DONALD TRUMP IS FOR NANCY PELOSI
AS SPEAKER BUT SETH MOULTON IS
NOT.
TRUMP IS COMFORTABLE WITH AND
SETH IN POWER, AND DONALD TRUMP
SEEMS VERY ENLIGHTENED.
THAT'S WHAT I SAY, WHY DO YOU
SEE SOMETHING DIFFERENT?
>> YOU ARE ASSIGNING WEIGHT TO
WHAT DONALD TRUMP SAID.
I THINK MOST DEMOCRATS AND
FRANKLY MOST PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY ANYMORE DON'T.
THEY JUST DON'T ASSIGNING WEIGHT
TO WHAT HE SAID.
>> I AM NOT FOR PELOSI.
I'M JUST USING THE RULES THAT
YOU GUYS MADE UP, AND IN FOREST
WITH GERMANIC EFFICIENCY ON THE
REST OF US.
THAT'S ALL I'M DOING.
IT FEELS BAD BECAUSE IT'S UNFAIR
AND STUPID.
CAN YOU ADMIT THAT?
AND THE REST OF US HAVE TO LIVE
LIKE THIS IN FEAR, AND MAYBE YOU
SHOULD LIVE LIKE THAT JUST FOR A
DAY TO SEE WHAT IT'S LIKE.
>> YOU ARE DESCRIBING THINGS
THAT I THINK DEMOCRATS AND THE
PUBLIC GENERALLY, THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE VOTED IN DEMOCRATS TO RUN